>>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, DOC?
CAN HE RIDE?
>> RIDE A HORSE?
AFRAID NOT, SON, THIS MAN'S LEG
IS BROKEN IN SIX PLACES.
>> WONDERFUL.
WHERE AM I GOING TO FIND ANOTHER
JOCKEY TEN MINUTES BEFORE THE
KENTUCKY DERBY?
>> I THINK I MIGHT KNOW SOMEONE,
SIR.
>> WHO?
>> SOMEONE GREAT.
>> WHERE IS HE?
>> BELIEVE ME, SIR, YOU'LL KNOW
HIM WHEN YOU SEE HIM.
>> YAH, YAH!
>> WHAT THE HECK?
♪♪
>> YEP, THAT'S ME.
RIDING A HORSE LIKE A
SKATEBOARD.
YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING HOW I
WOUND UP HERE.
WELL, IT'S KIND OF A CRAZY
STORY.
AND IT GOES A LITTLE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
♪ SO THERE I WAS DOING SKATE
TRICKS AT THE PARK ♪
♪ THEN I JUMPED WITH TOO MUCH
FORCE AND I LANDED ON A HORSE ♪
>> GREAT SCOTT!
♪ IF I LEAN RIGHT OR LEFT HE'D
FOLLOW MY EVERY MOVE ♪
♪ AND IF I WANTED HIM TO GO
FASTER I JUST GIVE HIM A BAG OF
CHIPS ♪
♪ WE WERE RUNNING REALLY HARD IN
MY NEIGHBOR'S BACKYARD ♪
>> NOT MY AZALEAS!
♪ HE CAN DO AN OLLIE AND A BACK
SIDE 182 ♪
♪ AND IF I ASK HIM NICELY HE'D
DO A KICK FLIP ♪
>> THIS GUY IS CRAZY!
♪ THEN WE WENT TO A TRACK AND WE
WON OUR VERY FIRST RACE ♪
♪ BUT AFTERWARDS HE DIDN'T STOP
SO WE TOURED THE UNITED STATES ♪
♪ I HOLD ON TO HIS TAIL WHEN WE
GRIND ON A RAIL ♪
♪♪
♪ THIS IS OUR LAST RACE CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE END ♪
♪ NEXT WEEK I HAVE TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND THEY SAY I CAN'T
BRING MY FRIEND ♪
♪ IT'S GONNA BE LONELY, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA DO ♪
♪ I HOPE THAT WHEN I'M GONE THEY
DON'T TURN HIM INTO GLUE ♪
>> WHOA!
>> HEY, I THINK I'M OKAY --
>> YEP, THAT PRETTY MUCH SUMS IT
UP.
THAT'S HOW I WON THE KENTUCKY
DERBY.
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW IT?
THEY EVEN MADE A VIDEO GAME
ABOUT MY LIFE, TOBY BIRD PRO
JOCKEY.
NOT BAD FOR A GUY THAT DIED
LATER THAT DAY.
NOT BAD AT ALL.